-These are our favorite
"Jokes of the Week."
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
According to sources,
former National Security Advisor
John Bolton
told conservative donors
he thinks President Trump
is mentally unstable,
but I'm sure Trump
will clear up that misconception
with 150 tweets at 3:00 am
[ Laughter ]
Senator Mitt Romney
was seen today
drinking chocolate milk
during the impeachment trial
and then, right after,
he failed a breathalyzer test.
[ Laughter ]
State lawmakers in Kentuck
have proposed a bill
that would require schools
to start teaching sex ed
in kindergarten.
Said a Kentucky first grader
"Oh, man,
that really would've
been helpful
before my wedding night!"
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
Republican Senator Mike Brau
this weekend said that he hope
impeachment will serve
as a learning experience
for President Trump, saying,
"I think he'll
put 2 and 2 together."
Because if there's
one thing we know
about a man who has
bankrupted three casinos,
it's that he's good at math.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A New York woman has admitte
that she is responsible
for sending her boyfriend
to the emergency room
24 times last year
by secretly putting pesticides
in his food.
When he asked the doctor wha
to take for that, she said
"The hint."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]